in order to make any sense of this we
have to rewind a little bit because this
is the act in a BiPAP story so we need
to go back just a little bit now
everyone was caught algebraic
manipulation is one of these actually I
think it was the first thing that we
started off this year doing we learnt a
few different skills or we reviewed a
few different skills and I want to jog
your memory because when you see these
you'll see how they connect what we're
going to do in hand three conveniently
all three of the things that we looked
at under and what they all start with on
then up yes I promise I didn't do that
on purpose that's just what the silver
says the first thing that we looked at
in lots of different kinds of ways was
simplifying things we learn to simplify
algebra now there's lots of different
ways that you can simplify algebra the
first thing is just with arithmetic what
is rithmetic mean arithmetic I suppose
is arithmetic for us is kind of
synonymous to like math in general but
actually everything is just one little
part of it it's all of those
calculations and operations you do is
four main ones you add you subtract
multiplying you divide right so this is
what arithmetic means and we did all of
these things without a bra you had an
expression you had to add some things
together when you add things together
now draw and they collapse into one
thing what we call that okay we call it
yeah like terms we call that collecting
like terms that was one of the specific
phrases that we learned and we're going
to do a bit more of them shortly okay we
also I think I heard that word
factorizing we saw like a bunch of terms
and they had something in common do you
remember that
so we factorized what's the opposite of
factorizing it's expanding oh good so
all of these come under the umbrella of
simplifying things all right you get
given some odd read it's a bit of a mess
but you can work with it and make it
look better than what it was before you
can make a look simpler okay
after super
sometimes you got given an expression
and those printing rooms right they
stand for numbers so we would give you
numbers and allows you to put them into
that expression what's that call it's
not a substitution substitution very
good this is a really big deal of
because pretty much every other unit
that we've done since native one has
involved substitution of some kind right
like think back to your focus study on
driving you'd need to take like a speed
and substitute into an equation of found
out how far you work or you have to take
a time and a number of hours and you
have to substitute that into and how
many drinks you've had to work out your
blood-alcohol content
okay so that's why this skill is so
important because we just keep using
your phone over and over never different
there's one more school you look at a
name one can remember if you get given
an equation you have to do something -
it's all sold so we would hate you an
equation and maybe a pronumeral in it
and you'd say hey can you find out what
the preview is what's the solution okay
that was a 1 and there's some links from
that into ampere which I'm going to
point out in a second but let's just do
it in order and to me what the title of
m2 was because I have a relation with
this funnel this was interpreting linear
relationships even in relations is ring
a bell okay now again we had three main
skills this is not exhaustive but it
gives you the main there were three main
skills that came under this okay the
first thing is this is straight lines so
what we did we do this was we'd rhythm
we would draw and when it's on like a
set of axes and it's properly done in
their own numbers we don't just call it
a drawing or a mine we call the ground
what kinds of there's too many important
features autograph does you remember
what they are
okay so I mean apart from the actual
axes which are the same every time but
the one itself right it's gonna have a
great year
that's so that's how steep the ladies is
it going up is it going down
this is drink fast or slow there's one
other thing you need yeah good I suppose
I put intercept
together but why they said usually was
the one that was the most appointment
okay so we drew graphs what else do we
do okay very good so when we said okay
she's it here's a graph right well it's
time to an equation and then we'd say
well what does that equation mean like
there are letters in here printables but
what did they stand for are they like
save time and money are they cost and
how many books you sold all that kind of
thing so what we called that if you
remember was a model you take a
situation like how much money you were
trying to earn or have faster driving or
how many oranges you bought you take an
actual situation and then you use one of
these straight lines so model is that
make sense now the very very last thing
we did was a bit tricky maybe you want
to draw this very briefly over here on
the side got a set of axes right I
wonder if you manage some of the
specific questions we did for example
the costs of constructing or printing
rather like a number of books like if
you were a book publisher i suppose the
cost associated with are how much money
you would make as you recoup those costs
when you actually solve books do you
remember this - member see if necessary
agents so that's right now what we would
look at for instance is I'm something
called the break-even point that's where
the costs that you've put in and the
amount of money that you're actually
getting back it's where they meet like
right there
that's when your costs and your profits
have exactly lined up and then after
that the more books you sell you make
one more profit right so in other words
what we were doing is we were finding
maybe when we try to solve for the point
of intersection so it's solving urban is
a different kind it's not just one
equation is actually a pair of code like
this one has one this one has one we
generally did it legally we'd say hey
look at a graph and you'd have to like
you remember you'd get a grid on there
and you'd have to do is best you could
to match up where the lines it was and
that's what we did okay what so this
sets the stage now we're actually going
to talk about the area
now that titles of these were as
regulation and interpreting linear
relationships now usually I have to kind
of um twist and turn to make like an ice
cream out of something but this time I
don't have to do it at all
because the title and 3b is well no it's
just nice how would you break and so
it's first now what are we gonna look at
in an three again are you getting the
hint it's gonna be three main things the
first thing is we're gonna revisit
something we looked at in stage 5
actually a little bit even in your
summary which is indices do you see it's
the power of the top right it's like x
squared or X cubed or something like
that okay so we're going to come back to
those and everything you did up here
with arithmetic with collecting my terms
each of those we're going to rehearse
those skills but we're gonna involve
indices okay so that's the first thing
secondly we're going to work on a skill
which I call rearrangement so think of
some equations you've seen before even
something as simple as this so we did
mmm form recently and that had circles
in it remember that so this is a formula
it's an equation it tells you the area
of a circle if you know its radius does
that make sense so you pop radius in and
then you just get out the answer but
sometimes you don't actually want to
find out the area based on the radius
sometimes you have it the other way
around right you have a certain amount
of area this is actually what I need to
do do everyone I made that diagram with
the
I had to work this out I wanted to know
the radius if I knew the area so you can
see this equation is not set up to do
that right now I had to rearrange it
another one where you seen this is this
equation this is what your formula sheet
what does it tell you that this is
president future value okay now what
this equation tells you is future value
provided you know what present value and
interest rate but you can rearrange this
in fact that formula sheet does exactly
that to get it the other way around
does that make sense so we call it we do
this another fancy name as well
we call it changing the subject so the
subject of an equation just like the
subject of a sentence is the main theme
in this cases area that's the subject in
this case is the future value right so
that's the important tie that everything
else tells you about and we can change
that we can we can rearrange it okay
lastly remember had a of two we look at
a graph like that and then we would do
the best we could zoom in on our laptop
screen to try and match up the lines we
would solve it visually right but
everyone knew that was like not very
accurate really like you got as best as
you could but it was never precise okay
so in this topic on om3 we're gonna
solve what you're doing again this
hasn't maybe you've seen before these
are simultaneous equations because some
TVs means what again it's at the same
time in other words we're 11 crash
existing at the same time but we're
gonna do better than just looking in a
graphic right that's just gonna give us
an approximate on something we're going
to do it algebraically which is good for
two reasons number one saves your time
because you don't need to draw the
things number two it's precise you get
an exact answer and that's kind of a bit
of a superpower okay